Optimal at this altitude,
I can run flat out for a half mile
before my hands start shaking.
I'm a cybernetic organism living tissue.
This episode is brought to you by
99 designs, whether you need a logo,
custom website, APP, book
cover, or anything else.
99 designs was created to make great
design accessible to everyone that's you
and to make the process
as easy as possible.
I've used 99 designs for years now.
I've used them for book covers,
some mock ups for the four hour body,
which went on to become a number
one New York Times best seller.
Illustrations of all different types
for the multivolume, the Tao of Seneca,
which you can check out and other graphic
design projects for a long time now
and I've been very impressed
by the quality of their
designers and illustrators
and you don't have to take my word for it.
You should check out some of my
projects@ninetyninedesigns.com
forward slash.
Tim, I really encourage you to take
a look because you will be impressed.
99 designs.com forward slash Tim nine
nine designs has freelance experts in more
than 90 design categories
in their platform.
Lets you work directly with
one designer that you choose.
If you like their stuff,
which is what I did for the Tao of Seneca,
or you can get concepts from multiple
designers and then pick your favorite.
So whether you're starting a business
or just looking for extra design, help,
resources,
etc. 99 designs has a solution right now.
You guys,
my listeners can receive a free
$99 upgrade on your first design.
To check out your first free upgrade,
please visit 99 designs.com forward slash
Tim and click the link on the landing
page. You can also find their
samples of projects from you guys,
listeners who've used 99
designs for logos, apps,
even product packaging,
so check it out.
99 designs.com forward slash.
Tip.
This episode is brought to you by
wordpress.com I love wordpress.
I have used it for so many years.
It's my goto platform for
blogging and creating websites.
I use wordpress.com for everything.
Every day. My site. Tim.
Dot blog is built on it. The websites
for my books, including tools of titans,
tribe of mentors. It's all
in wordpress.com and the
founder Matt Mullenweg,
one of my close friends has
appeared on the show many times.
Just search Matt Mullenweg,
Tequila Ferris for quite an exciting time.
Whether you're looking to create a
personal blog, a business site, or both,
you can make a really big impact
right out of the box when you build on
wordpress.com and you'll be
in good company. It's used
by the New Yorker, Jay Z,
Beyonce, five 38 tech crunch, Ted, CNN,
and time just to name
a handful and one of my
friends@googlewhoshallremainnamelesshastoldmethatwordpress.com
offers
the
best
out of the box SEO imaginable and quote,
and it's one of the many reasons that
nearly 30% of the Internet is run on
wordpress.
You do not need experience or to hire
someone that's perhaps the best part.
wordpress.com guide you
through the entire experience.
They have hundreds of
designs and templates that
you can use and it's easy to
get started. There's no need to
worry about security upgrades,
hosting any of that. They have for
24 seven support and they're very,
very responsive. If you have
questions, they get right back to you.
And this allows you to create the
highest quality with the least amount of
headache and friction. So if
you're building a website, period,
when my friends come to me and ask
what I use, what I recommend they use,
the answer is wordpress.com
so check it out.
Do you want to get started today?
Learn more with a 15%
discount off any new plan.
Go to wordpress.com forward slash Tim
to create your website and find the plan
that's right for you. So
learn more. Take a look,
wordpress.com forward slash Tim
for 15% off a brand new website.
Check it out.
Hello boys and girls.
This is Tim Ferriss and welcome to another
episode of the Tim Ferriss Show where
it is my job to deconstruct
world class performers,
people who are exceptionally good at
what they do. To tease out the routines,
habits,
favorite books,
and so on that you can hopefully
test and apply to your own lives.
And my guest today is none
other than drew Houstin,
h. O u s t o n at drew Houstin
on Twitter and elsewhere.
He's the cofounder and CEO of Dropbox
since founding the company in 2007 with a
rush for dozy,
drew has led the company's growth from
a simple idea to a service used by 500
million people around the world.
You can let that number sink in.
Drew received his bachelor's degree
in electrical engineering and computer
science from Mit in 2006 I think I've
heard of that place. After graduating,
he turned his frustration with carrying
USB drives and emailing files to himself
into a demo for what then became Dropbox.
Today,
Dropbox is one of the world's leading
business collaboration platforms with 11
million paying subscribers and 1800
plus employees across 12 global offices.
Drew, welcome to the
show. Thank you. You know,
I've wanted to have an excuse to ask
you for your life story and all of these
details because we've known
each other quite a while,
but it's super weird to sit down with
a glass of wine at a dinner table or
something like that and just start
asking you for your doctor evil story.
So this is, this is a fun
opportunity for me to dig in.
So I appreciate you taking the time.
Awesome. Yeah, me too. It's a, it's,
it's great to be here and,
uh,
thought we would start with some of the
backstory that I do not know and that is
your childhood.
And perhaps you could just begin by
telling us how you would describe yourself
as a kid.
I mean,
let's call it kind of three
to grade or anytime really.
What type of kid were you?
So yeah, going way back. Um,
well first I was,
uh,
I was definitely that kid
who is a on computers. So we,
my parents, I remembered, uh, just like,
like titling into my living room and
seeing this glowing orb and all these
buttons. And those were two things
I really liked when I was three. Um,
I guess still do. Um, and
um, so for sure I was,
I was super interested in computers
and technology and started out by,
by playing computer or video
games. Basically. That was
like the first interest.
And then I wanted to make
my own computer games. Um,
I thought that my career was going to be
starting a computer game company and I
thought that was a, that there would
be nothing better than that. Um, and,
uh, so I, but I, but I
was that kid, I'm sorry.
I learned programming at an
early age. Um, I grew up in,
uh, just outside of Boston, so grew
up in New England. Um, and, uh,
and then on my way to MIT, I've really
liked math, science. Um, so, uh,
kind of out of central casting in terms
of being a computer science student. Um,
and then, yeah, and then, then I got,
my first career was babysitting,
but then I discovered that you could be
paid to program and then that caused a
bit of a career shift,
which we can talk about. Um,
uh, as much as I enjoyed the
babysitting lifestyle, you know,
you get like three bucks an hour,
I eat some Pringles watched the HBO,
it's not that bad. Um, but, uh,
the program is even better anyway.
So, um, so, uh, so, but in,
in middle school and in high school I
ended up getting a bunch of programming
internships or, or, or summer jobs, um,
at what worst our bed startups
basically. Um, one of the most remote,
most of them are local, but then that got
me on a path of starting companies and,
and being involved in startups. But, um,
I would say those are probably the, um,
the biggest when it,
when it,
when it comes to Dropbox and everything
that kind of followed after to from my
childhood. It was a happy
childhood. Lots of, um,
uh, say it was still
pretty balanced. But I did,
I like programming and engineering
was for sure my first, my first love.
And were you a shy kid
and extroverted kid?
Played Sports, kind of kept to
yourself at recess? What was,
what would somebody looking in from
the outside? Like, how would your,
how would your third grade teacher
describe you in that capacity?
Yeah, I think somewhere in the middle.
So I, I wasn't, um, reclusive. Um,
I had a really group of friends. Um, I
wasn't captain of the soccer team either.
Um, I think I did, I did academic,
I did academic decathlon,
which is just a fascinating
thing that it exists.
Um, but you know, more of
a math leads then right.
Then an athlete to athlete.
So, um, but uh, and I was,
yeah,
it was not like a super social,
but I had a good group of friends
and um, um, and then for sure it was,
I went into college,
I became a lot more social and,
and just curious about humans
and human behavior. Um,
but, uh, but otherwise I think people
like I would have been known in class,
um,
as always doing it.
Like,
I think there were like those
superlatives and yearbooks.
I think I was like most likely to start
a company or it'd be like they pegged it
pretty early. Yeah. So I
was doing homework for this,
which I always enjoy doing
when it's someone I know, uh,
because I dig up all these bits and
pieces that I then want to fair it out and
explore a bit.
So I came across this line,
the described folding chair
on top of fraternity, uh,
at MIT and that you would go up there
with piles of books and read these books.
So I don't like could you place us when
that was in your undergrad career and
how you chose the books and
why you did that? Yeah, so, so
I, it was about my junior
year of, uh, of, of Undergrad,
I took a leave of absence because I had
an idea for a startup that I want it to
pursue. Um, so I took a
year off to do that. Uh,
what I noticed was that the,
this was back in 2004, so the,
I was maybe 21 and the,
uh, sat was changing.
I started online sat
prep company and maybe,
and because what the opportunity was was
the sat was changing in 240 2005 from
1600 points to 2,400 points.
So suddenly all the course material
overnight was going to be obsolete.
And so I saw an opportunity
to maybe develop,
not just a course for the
new sat but an online course.
And I teamed up with a former teacher
from my high school who had his own little
cottage sat prep company and I'm
like, Hey, if we come together,
we can put this thing online and we'll
be on an even playing field because, um,
you know,
all those 800 page books that have been
printed about it are now a obsolete and
who really wants to go to some classroom
at eight in the morning on Saturday.
Um, anyway, like we can build a much
better experience if we do it online. So,
um,
I was really excited about starting a
company and we jumped into it and I think
we met in a Chili's and like we're
planning world domination
and like figuring out, okay,
how do you incorporate a
company? And so it's really, um,
introduction to the world of
starting companies. And then, um,
it was, uh, it also,
the more I learned about the mechanics of,
of starting a company, the more I realized
I didn't know about business. Um, and I,
and I knew a lot about in engineering
and programming and, um, I had been,
I had worked at startups but when
it came to one w but it was kind of,
there was a fog beyond just like
building the product. And so I was like,
all right, we're going to need, I know
like sales and marketing and strategy,
like these are all things and all I know
is I don't know a lot about them. So, um,
I had the highly scientific method
of, I just was like, all right,
I'm just gonna go on to Amazon,
type in sales by the top three or four
books and just do that for every like
category.
Um,
and then I had a couple of
book recommendations from
one of the founders of one
of the companies where I worked
as well. But, uh, but it was,
it was great and it was, it was,
it was an important combination.
So if one was one was actually starting,
the company gave me motivation to really
learn this stuff because I think a lot
of times when you're reading it can
just be like entertainment basically.
It's like something where you just
like read the book, you'll like,
that's interesting,
but then don't use the knowledge
to actually starting a company.
Then you really have an excuse to
internalize and really study the material.
So there's a big difference between
reading the material and studying it.
Totally. But I was pretty
systematic about it and like, okay,
here's all the stuff that
I don't know and, um,
and then is going to be a good way to get
me introduced to all these topics. Um,
and all of that. Maybe the first
instance of that was when, um,
you know,
I went through my high school and I was,
and there were a lot of great books that
you read as part of your, um, you know,
high school curriculum. But, um,
then I stumbled across the book
emotional intelligence by Daniel Goleman.
And I was like, oh my God. Like
this has just like, it's, I mean,
it's nonfiction. Um, but it, it,
it spelled out something that was,
I just didn't know you could kind
of break down in a logical way.
And suddenly I have this understanding
about the world that I didn't have before.
Um, and so that was
important because it sort of,
it was sort of one of a bunch of early
examples that anything is trainable.
And, and, and it,
it got me on a path to developing what
we'd now call a growth mindset. Um,
and realizing that it's possible to learn
about these things that you were where
you have no experience or
where it's easy to be like, oh,
I don't know about that or I'm just an
engineer. I'm not a business person. Um,
and kind of shatter that misconception.
Do you think that you were open to all
of these different categories of learning
because of the necessity
vis-a-vis starting the company?
The reason I asked that is that,
uh, it's, it's not across the board,
but some people with engineering
chops have seemed to have a learned or
intrinsic disdain for sales marketing.
This different bits and
pieces of businesses that are
a little softer, let's say,
less quantifiable in some
respects. Uh, was it,
was it simply the motivation in building
this company where we had to write a,
or rather wear all those hats that
kind of drove you into these different
categories? Or where are you
intrinsically using that word quite a bit,
but interested in learning more about
these different buckets through these
different books?
Well,
I think it was a little of both.
So certainly starting the company
made it a necessity and created a lot,
a lot of additional motivation.
But the experience,
I also found these other topics, uh, just
as interesting as, as the engineering.
Um, and I, and I think it's, yeah,
it's a big cultural when engineers, um,
start off by being dismissive or defensive
about that the technology is all that
matters or if it doesn't have a
triple and a girl in Greek letters,
it doesn't count.
Certainly was certainly like
a cultural meme at Mit. Um,
and I think it just creates a
huge blind spot for people, um,
both because it makes them less effective.
But it's also like, the stuff is,
is actually really interesting and,
but I kept having experiences like
that and the emotional intelligence,
which is just one example,
but I took a class on negotiation and MIT,
which sort of opened my eyes a notch
further on this kind of thing where I'm
like, all right, negotiation. I go into
that class. I don't know a lot about it.
I'm like, whoever like yells louder
lies more, smacks the table harder,
I guess that's what makes
you get negotiator. Um,
and then this class like, I mean
those are, those are tactics,
but like the class has these
frameworks where like, okay, it's more,
people have thought about this and
they've broken it down. Um, and you,
and it turns out that there's a whole
process of uncovering mutual interests and
figuring out what your leverage
is and your best alternative
Dah, Dah, Dah. And so,
and, and spelling it out
in a way where I was like,
actually this is a lot more straight
forward than some of the theoretical math
classes I'm, I'm, I have to take. Um,
and it's a lot more applicable
to my daily life. And so,
um,
I started to,
I really appreciated like learning a
little bit about a lot of different
disciplines and in just putting up a
folding chair on my roof was the first
thing that came to mind as far
as how I could actually do that.
Were there any other books besides
emotional intelligence during that period
that really had an impact on you?
Yes. So in that negotiation classes
book called getting to yes. Um,
which is about principle negotiation.
Um,
and I still think about a lot of those
I still think about and apply a lot of
those concepts, um, today.
And then some of the,
so part of it was just like kind of
doing a random walk, Amazon. But, um,
I also became friends with the founders
of the companies where I worked. Um,
and I went during lunch breaks or at
other times I go like chase him down and
bug them and ask them questions
about like, hey, how do
you start a company? Like,
do you have any book recommendations?
I'm just making that kind of taking
advantage of being the bright eyed,
bushy tailed intern,
um,
and shaking down my
boss or my mentor or my,
the founder or my mentors for,
for advice.
And so two of the books that
were really instrumental, uh,
the first one is the innovator's
dilemma by Clay Christiansen. Um,
it's a book about how businesses
get disrupted and, um, and what,
and it's a big part,
a lot of those themes or why startups can
succeed and thrive even when there are
big competitors who you would
think would just wipe them out. Um,
and so how that cycle works. And there's
a book called crossing the Chasm,
which is another classic. Yeah, it's a
book on marketing, technology, marketing.
It's like how did,
how do you,
how do technology products make their way
from early adopters to the mainstream?
And if you find yourself
revisiting those books,
or were they a point in time during
that rooftop Amazon education period?
I have, I met, I'd say there are
a lot of, you read a lot of books.
Not all of them are as good as the
innovator's dilemma, but then yeah, it,
it also helps to revisit some of the
classics. Uh, innovator's dilemma is,
I've actually, both of those books
are good examples, so, so yeah,
I do revisit them because again, when
you're 21 and you've never had a real job,
you know, you're, you're,
you're reading this book and you sort
of get a general sense for things,
but you don't,
you don't really deeply understand the
concepts and then coming back five years
later, 10 years later, you can really
absorb a lot more of that material.
So I do, I, I read a lot of books in
general and then when I'm reading a book,
I'll triage them like, okay, is
this something I need to study?
Is it something that's like interesting
or is it that I might need to know
something about or is it just
fun? Um, and if you study it,
if I'm like,
I need to study this book,
then I approach it pretty differently
than if it's just like entertainment.
And for those people who
haven't read getting to, yes.
When you were leading into that with
some of the concepts from the class.
I thought to myself,
I bet that was part of the class or
one of the books you read because you,
you had best alternative and there's
a term I do recommend also people read
getting to yes, Batna, best
alternative to negotiated agreement,
which is a really
important concept to grasp.
And there's another book
that I recommend to people.
I think it was written later by one of
the coauthors of getting to yes called
getting past to know and I think they
go together really, really nicely.
Uh,
if you were teaching,
say we're just going to stick on books
for a little bit because I know you read
so much.
If you were teaching saying a freshmen
class or senior class Undergrad,
uh,
to,
let's just say smart but non technical
people and you were assigning books to
read, uh, and uh, they can be
part of the class or things,
it could be read in advance.
If you were to pick,
I'm just pulling this out of thin air,
but three to five books that would be
sort of the core of your reading list.
Uh, do any come to mind that we,
that we haven't talked about?
So for this,
for the sake of starting earth,
if the subject of the class,
we're starting a company yeah. Um,
or evolving from being an engineer
to being a business person.
Um, I have a few, I have a handful of,
of books that I really love
and the concepts I still,
that I use and think
about every day. So, um,
probably my two favorites are a high
output management by Andy Grove,
um,
which Andy Grove was the CEO of Intel,
which was kind of the
Google of its time back, uh,
in the particular back in the
eighties and early nineties.
So he,
Andy was an engineer,
one of the founding engineers and then
rose the ranks at Intel and became CEO.
So he, he's lived his path. And,
and when I read about that or I heard
about this book and it was introduced me
as the best book on
management ever written. Um,
and I agree and it just breaks
down all the mechanics of um,
okay. How, how do you run a team?
How do you break down a
goal and to into sub goals?
How do you just the one on one
of, of, of, of running a team and,
and running an organization
and a focus on, uh,
output and results and how do you
measure people? And just a lot,
a lot of the things that you, nuts
and bolts, things that you, uh,
challenges that you encounter when
you're, when you're running a team. Um,
whether that's a company or
a team within a company. Um,
the second is the effective executive,
um, which does a great by Peter Drucker.
Um,
and the central
core of that book is really about people.
It's very easy to mistake
a effort for effectiveness.
Um, there are a lot of different
phrases for this, like, you know,
it to confuse motion for progress or,
but, but it's really about that idea.
So how do you, um, how do you know if
you're being effective, what practices?
And then there's a bunch of practices
that you can adopt that, um,
that make you more effective and then
how do you avoid the sand traps of things
that feel productive but aren't actually,
um,
and how do you deal dissects or how do
you unpack the case where we all have the
same number of hours in a day,
but some of us seem to accomplish
a lot more than others.
The why is that and what
can you do instead? So the,
the effective executive is,
it covers a lot of that crowns that,
that's another,
those two I think of is kind of like
textbooks. Like you want to study them,
you want to take notes,
you want to really chew on the material.
Um, then I, I think there's others,
there's a lot of other tactical
things about starting a company.
I'd say some more of the,
uh,
favorite book that's more about the
experience of running a company is Ben
Horowitz's book hard thing
about hard things, right?
Which is kind of just shows you kind of
a mess and adventure and the crazy highs
and lows of,
of,
and like with the human experiences
of actually having to do this. Um,
and then I probably zoom out and
get a little more philosophical. Um,
so a couple of favorite books are,
um,
poor Charlie's Almanack by Charlie monger.
So Charlie Munger is Warren Buffett's
longtime business partner. Um, and um,
and one of the,
this book is really interesting because
one of the things about being a CEO or
taking on big responsibility,
um,
for anything is you have to make a lot
of decisions about a lot of different
things and do it quickly and be right.
Um,
and so how do you be right
about tons of different things,
especially if you don't have
a lot of life experience.
Like how do you train up
that scale quickly? I mean,
that's really called wisdom
or judgment. Um, and so the,
it says like, how do you, how do you
grow wisdom or grow judgment quickly? Um,
poor Charlie's Almanack is a,
is a great example of books.
So it talks about how actually a lot of
what you need to know to be successful
in life, conceptually, you learn it
in middle school or in high school,
you just don't apply it or you don't
really internalize the concepts. Um,
and he argues that a lot of really
wise ineffective people develop or be
basically build a catalog
of mental models, um,
where uh,
and concepts,
whether that's something
from and basically assemble
all the best ideas from all
the different disciplines and then
figure out how to apply them in life.
And so for example, the concept of, um,
a Batna like in and leverage that that
might be a concept that can be applied in
all kinds of different situations or
comparative advantage from economics or,
and, uh, or you know, you
could, you could go on about,
um,
these different concepts,
but then figuring out how
do you internalize them so
well that you're able to
figure out, okay, these are what matters
in these situations. Um, and then,
uh, and then how do you avoid petty
particularly avoid terrible decisions.
But really how do you build enough of it?
Get enough of these,
he calls it allowed us to work.
How do you build them enough of a network
of these mental models so that you
know which ones to apply when,
um,
and that you find yourself most of
the time being able to make good quick
decisions. Um, and then I'm
also on the philosophical front.
Uh, so zen and the art of motorcycle
maintenance. Yeah. Appear sick. Yup.
Um,
so you talked about engineers who like
dismiss like all these things that can't
be fit into an algorithm
or uh, or, or you know,
that don't have some kind
of like mathematical rigor,
rigor underpinning them. Um,
zen in the art of motorcycle
maintenance is about that. Like that.
Just that question of okay,
you have like this whole rational world
which can explain a bunch of stuff,
but then you have the
whole aesthetic world,
which can't be boiled down to a formula.
And they both exist and they are
both useful in different cases,
but they don't tend to get along. And so
how do you like, so what's up with that?
And then it's a really great book
about those kinds of concepts.
And I think developing
an appreciation for,
for both are developing both your left
and right brain, you know, to, to,
to use that analogy I think
is really important if you're,
if you're running a team or,
or growing a company. Um,
because there's a lot of stuff where
it's a lot about technique and data and,
and um,
and sort of like,
and a lot of things like
strategy or the engineering,
how are kind of fall into these if this,
then that kind of reasoning.
But then a lot of the hard part of the
job is really about people and what
motivates people. How do you, um,
paint a vision of the world
that's exciting for people?
How do you build good relationships?
Um,
how do you develop products with taste?
Uh,
those are things that are not going to
be where you're not able to reach as much
into the, to the more rational or
in or like kind of engineering, um,
bag of tricks. So I think
developing both of those, um,
developing both sides of your brain are
developing an appreciation for for both
is, is really valuable.
Um, maybe one more the,
so principles by Ray Dalio who was,
I know it was a recent guest.
Um, I think he's got just
really concise and good, um,
thoughts for like, all right. How
do you sort of approach all the,
um, how'd you approach life? So it's um,
I would include a mix of,
of of of different kinds of things.
I'd have like more instructional books,
like more philosophical books.
Um,
more story in history kind of books.
Man. I don't want to take your class.
I'm like, yes, that's pretty good.
That was pretty good.
Number one. So consider me
preregistered or free preapplied.
I want to make a couple of comments on
these books that you mentioned because uh,
I, I am very fond of all
of these books and I'll,
I'll just add a couple of,
of notes because they tie
together also really nicely.
So high output management by Grove was
out of print at one point and then became
so popular in Silicon Valley
that a new edition was printed.
And the forward,
I believe was from Ben Horowitz who
wrote the another book that you had
mentioned. You know, the, what does it,
the hard thing about hard things, right?
And Ben Horowitz of Andreessen Horowitz
and many other things prior to that, uh,
to that book.
And there's of course a selection bias
here since I have a limited Dataset,
but the startups that I've been involved
with that have done best have kind of
returned to the fund many, many, many
times over almost without exception,
have all read high output management
and have a copy of it in their offices.
Uh,
th that's now I'm sure there are many
unsuccessful CEOs who also have that book,
but nonetheless, uh,
the effective executive,
actually I'm gonna
leave that one for last.
So poor Charlie's Almanack is a great
book and I want to underscore something
that you said a somewhat in passing or
which is really important and I know you,
you know,
it's really important,
which is the avoiding of
making really bad mistakes.
And one thing that monger
emphasizes a lot, you know,
the right hand of Warren Buffet in Warren.
It I guess I said he has the fat,
the best 62nd mind he's ever met. And
I'm going to butcher this, I'm sure,
but it's something that I think of a lot,
uh,
because I have some tendencies that are
unhelpful intro in shrine to be really
smart and come up with clever solutions.
And I said, I revisit this quote,
somebody could find the right version,
but it's monger who says, you know,
it's amazing how successful you can become
if you just consistently avoid being
stupid versus trying to
outsmart everybody else.
And I think a lot about that. Uh,
because it's so true. It's like God,
yeah, if you just kind of watch your chips
and know your downside and don't make,
you know, consistently make rational
decisions with these lattice works.
And these sharistics that you mentioned.
Super, super helpful, uh, and, uh,
the effective executive.
So the effective executive,
I want to come back to for a second.
And you mentioned nuts and bolts.
The effective executive,
I've read probably 10 or 12 times.
I love this book and it's, it's
very short too. It's easy to read.
And you mentioned the
sort of nuts and bolts.
So I'm going to use this and then we'll
probably jump around chronologically,
but you,
uh,
if I'm remembering correctly,
have a label in your email called opp.
Uh,
could you explain for
people what this means?
Yes. So originally I think
originally, well, yeah, it was,
it stood for other people's problems.
Um,
although I made it a little nicer later.
Other people's priorities.
Um, and because I have a
vendetta against email,
which we can, um, we can, we can dig into,
but I, I'm, I'm, I've had this experience,
I imagine anyone listening is that
this experience, like, all right,
you're inbox overflowing or
like,
I'm finally going to deal with this thing.
You plow through hundreds of emails
and your reward is more emails.
Right? Um, but, but then to the OPP
opp thing, I'm like, wait, what?
Then what are these things
like what am I doing?
And then you realize that like you're
just basically checking off items on other
people's to do list. Um, where there's,
there's a sort of in the abstract,
there's nothing wrong with that and it's
important to be helpful and we all have
been helped by and help other people.
But, um, you can end up in a situation,
um,
where you're basically your to do list
is a composite of other people's to do
list and your calendar and your
email can often reflect that and uh,
and tying it to another. So one of the
most important concepts is focus. Um,
everybody understands like,
yeah, yeah, focus. Um,
and I imagined something we'll
probably talk more about here. Um,
but there, there are so
many forces. It will,
some people love the idea of focus and,
and,
and when it was interesting just
going back to Warren Buffett,
so Warren Buffet and Bill Gates
did an interview. Um, it's on,
I think it's on Netflix. There's
like a Warren Buffet documentary, um,
which is great. I also recommend,
but anyway, they, they, uh,
the interviewer ad, he was interviewing
both Warren and bill and was like,
all right in a word,
what has made you most successful?
And they both at the same time,
it's like without missing a beat,
those said focus. Um, and so if we all,
and it's like, seems so obvious
that we all know why focus is,
is like we don't need to be told why
focus is important. But then, uh,
and one of the things that
the effective executive, uh,
highlights is that there's so many,
like the default for pretty much
anything is to unfocus you. Um,
and that's true of your inbox, your
inbox, which is not prioritize.
It's just kind of like you basically
get all these requests that are other
people's priorities. Um, uh, if
you're working within an organization,
pretty much everybody we'll be pulling
on you to kind of feed the beast of the
organization. And so it becomes very hard
to do a few things. Well. Um, and so,
I mean there's a lot of great things
about that book, but, um, but yeah,
I do have an opp folder,
which I try to keep it
manageable or find ways to,
um, I think that best is if you can
find ways to be helpful budgeting,
like involve other people
and actually helping.
So I have a whole team of people
who can help me respond to, to,
to those,
those kinds of requests
sooner. The OPP folder, it's not this,
it's not necessarily a black hole. Uh,
it's not an indefinite
archive necessarily, but it's
when I'll get around to it.
Do you have a set schedule for looking
in the OPP folder or having other people
do that for you? And what are
the criteria? Right, if it,
is it that anything that doesn't come
from say a direct report or an investor or
a family member into opp or what are the,
what are the guidelines?
Yeah, so the, I think some people
would say feeling call even when I'm,
when I help. So I'm not great at
responding to these things. So, I mean,
it might be, if it's something
that's like not a priority,
then I'll try to respond
in days. But sometimes this
weeks, sometimes it's months,
sometimes, sometimes I'll give you, you'll
get a response that's like, oh yeah,
it's seven months later. It's like,
Oh, here is, you still need this. Um,
but, uh, so I, I would, I think it's, if,
if it is something from a person
you have a relationship with, um,
I would say [inaudible]
and there's probably other
factors, but it's like, okay,
is this someone who,
uh, I know and where I,
where I personally would
be really helpful, um,
and they have done their
homework and it's like, well,
I think there's a certain first pass
filters like that. Um, I would say,
uh,
there is no commandment from God that
you have to respond to every email you
receive. Um, so if,
if it's like a cold email cold
call or if it's like some,
some someone I don't know,
or it's like a sales thing or whatever,
I just, then it just goes into the black
hole. Um, or if it's something like,
you know, there's a lot of folks who
are like, Hey, I need, I need a mentor,
or how do I raise money? Or you can
often tell by the question, like,
as a person,
many if not most of the requests will
be something where the person could just
do a little bit of homework
and get a good answer. Um,
and that's troubling because at first you
try to help people with those kinds of
things. You're like, oh, well, you know,
go to this blog post or do this thing. Um,
and then you don't hear back from them
and it turns out they just never followed
up or just didn't do it.
And so after you get burned by spending
a bunch of time trying to be helpful to
people who don't do their homework,
who don't help themselves,
you realize it's like not how you
want to spend your life. Um, so,
so you have to, you know, I think, I
don't think there's a magic formula, but,
but I think you want to just
keep what you want to do.
Just keep that budget of you're time
constrained to something small. Yeah.
Or at least over small or big,
you should at least be mindful of it.
A lot of people just and find themselves
hopelessly busy and on this treadmill
responding to other people's,
um, to do lists and,
and knowing no one is doing
the things on their to do list.
Right. Yeah. One thing you said
about people doing their homework,
uh,
reminded me of this quote from Maria
Popova who writes brain pickings,
which is this incredible site,
millions and millions of readers and
really long forms, smart writing.
And at some time I think she
changed it to be a little, uh,
more, uh, maybe sunny
seeming, but she had a quote,
I'm pretty sure on her
Facebook page as the graphic,
as the header at one point that said,
if you haven't done or if someone hasn't
done the homework to determine, uh,
whether it's a fit or not,
it doesn't warrant the energy to explain
why it isn't a fit or something like
that,
which I think is a great commandment,
uh,
or sort of guideline to use because so
much of it when you reinforce that type
of behavior by trying to be helpful,
they just come back.
People tend to come back with equally
nebulous or unthought through questions.
Uh,
do you have any other best practices
or do's or do nots when it comes to,
to managing email? We're
not using email. Yeah.
Try not to use a lot of email.
Um, because often if it's,
um, I think emails for is good
for quick discrete tasks, um,
where you're holding someone up by not
doing them. But if you're trying to,
uh, and then I think it's also
useful to like for broadcasts,
like if you have something, if you
have some long form written, um,
direction that you want to give
a group of people, um, then then,
then that's a good use of it.
Um,
but often when people get into
these long email threads, uh,
it's often,
uh,
it's sometimes we fun and indulgent
to get into these big like flame wars.
But often the best way to if,
if, if you get along email,
often the best response is to
talk to them in person. Um,
and if you're getting a
lot of little requests,
it's better to just batch them up and
have some kind of weekly cadence where you
can deal with a lot of quick
requests without having the
overhead of, uh, of, um,
uh, of email. And I think that this is,
these are all kind of email is just one
example of a lot of different forces
that can take away that can kind
of shatter your attention, um,
or take away your time.
Um, I think one of the,
one of the most valuable concepts
from the effective executive is,
is measuring your time and early
understanding where your time goes. Um,
and it is kind of shocking and Hilarious,
but really tragic that we all think
we know exactly where our time goes.
Um,
but then when you measure it,
you're not usually just like slightly
wrong and you're like totally upside down.
Um, so, um,
this is a really valuable exercise for
anyone but actually like keeping a log of
like where you spend your
time, um, and categorizing it.
I remember the first time I did this,
did this, I was like, all right,
I'm running a company. It's things
are going well. I probably what,
what do I spend my time on? Oh,
back then it was PR. I was like,
I want to spend my time on the product
and recruiting and Dah, Dah, Dah. Um,
and when I actually did
the, the, the inventory, um,
like I was spending like no time
on those things. I was spending a,
there was a lot of, yeah, a
lot of opp back then. Like,
just like responding to fit,
like following up on favors or speaking
engagements that didn't really do
anything for the company.
And there wasn't like a lot of tea,
like total fat like that.
But um,
but it just might [inaudible] what you
find is you write down your priorities
and you look at your time and you find
that things are totally mismatched.
And so any mechanism you can, uh, to,
um, to first understand where your time
goes and then make sure your priorities
actually match it.
I think at the end of the day,
that's conceptually what you want to
do a and then just understand that,
um, you're going to attend and
then you also want to offset the,
the tendency for to be in this
permanently. We reactive state.
Um,
which,
whether that's cause you're getting
emails that are other people's requests or
your calendar says one
thing. Um, usually when you,
your to do list gets too long.
You just try to,
you just sort of do things randomly
or just do whatever the last thing,
you're just respond to whatever showed
up most recently in her inbox or what
blinked at you or what yelled
at you loudest in the last hour.
Um, and that's not a, that's not
effective. Um, compared to having,
setting your own priorities and
measuring yourself against them. Um,
and this is separate topic,
but I think technology needs to do a
lot better job of helping us do that
because it's really hard.
And then,
especially as you're in any kind
of organization, um, you're gonna,
you're gonna the, the, the, the fires
will get dealt with first and that's,
that's not a bad thing. Um, or
that, that's like necessary.
You can't not put out the fires,
but then the important stuff, the,
I'd say Eisenhower had this
work versus virgin. Yeah.
The matrix that are the quadrants,
I guess it was the two by two
is an important and urgent and,
um, eliminating stuff that's
not important. Not Urgent, but,
but really the biggest prior crisis of
prioritization is like how do you make
sure that you do, um,
that you elbow out time,
the important not urgent stuff because
the important and urgent stuff will get
taken care of.
But then you end up with a lot of
stuff that's not important or urgent,
not important or not important,
not urgent.
And you really want to cut those down
as much as possible because otherwise a
lot of the fires,
if you actually do root cause analysis,
I think about like why did,
why was this fire in the first place when
you kind of climb that ladder a couple
of rungs?
Like why did this happen,
why this happened or why it happened
cause that well, why did that happen?
Because of that.
Um,
you find that just a little
bit of planning would have,
would have eliminated the need to
fight that fire. Um, and so, but it,
and it's really easy to spend your days
kind of doing the equivalent of paying,
paying down a lot of like high interest
credit card debt with your time by just
doing, fighting all these fires and not
actually putting them out at their root.
Um, so something I do on that
front now is I, I've, uh, uh,
there's a concept called
no meeting Wednesday,
which I think is popular around the
valley and maybe it originated Facebook,
I'm not sure,
but we've sort of Ha halfheartedly
adopted that and I half heartedly adopted
that for awhile. But I
remember there was a, I'm like,
I really want to do this because there's
all this planning and like all these
things that are important that that
where the cost of me not creating clarity
for my team is super high.
Um,
and I sat down with my assistant at the
time and I was like, Hey, I need to like,
please don't schedule stuff on
Wednesday. Like, it's really, uh,
it's really important that I work on
this particular project and, you know,
it's just not going to get
done unless there's some,
unless I have like a full day or like
many hours of uninterrupted time.
And she's like, but she's
like, but blah, blah,
blah has this and it's important and blah,
blah,
blah, blah has this and it's important.
And I'm like,
there will never be a day where there
isn't something quote important, you know,
coming up. Um, and so, uh, it, it's dawned
on me in that conversation, but I'm like,
this shit, this is all important.
Like, eh, but it's not in.
And so, um, I was like, look, just,
I really want it. If, if, if it is
important, just schedule it on Saturday,
I'll come into the office,
I'll do all those things.
And then miraculously,
those things kind of ended
up doing themselves and
adopting no meeting Wednesday
was utterly transformative in terms of,
of actually being able to think and make
progress on the most important thing.
Because otherwise you just,
you lift up your head and you finally
six months have passed on some important
on quote important priority of
yours and there's been no progress.
So thinking about how to develop
systems and how do you build in time for
reflection and an elbow
at the time, um, for,
for you to think and set direction.
I think that's,
that's probably one that's one of the
biggest mistakes that people make.
And one of the concepts from effective
executive is like a lot of that stuff
only makes pro,
that doesn't,
that that stuff doesn't make progress
with a half hour slot in a meeting of 10
or an a day of 10 hours of
half hour meetings like you,
there's a minimum quantum of time for
deep thought or deep work that you need.
Um, and so anyway, there's a
lot of really conceptual found,
a great conceptual foundations and
effective executive about your time and
effectiveness and disability,
waiting buisiness from effectiveness
and then the concept of leverage in high
upper management, um, and a
focus on output. So those,
those two books have pretty much
conceptually everything you need.
But then implementing it in
practice is a lot harder.
Yeah. We're, we're going to talk about
the practice all, all quite a bit.
I think also in this conversation,
I want to circle back to a few things
you mentioned because I think they're
really important. Uh, the,
the first is the Eisenhower Matrix.
I think it might be
referred to as, uh, which,
which people can look up
on their own time. But the,
the correlating in some respects,
maybe exercise that I think Drucker brings
up and the effective executive is the
jar or a mason jar. And if people
can visualize this very easily,
but if you have a mason jar
and next to the Mason Jar,
you have a handful of large
rocks that can fit into the jar.
Then you have a bunch of smaller pebbles
and then you have a pile of sand,
all of which has come out of the jar.
If you put in the big rocks first,
I your sort of most critical tasks,
which may or may not be urgent,
then you can fit in the pebbles and
then you can fit it in the sand.
And you scroll on the top
and it's nice and neat,
but if you put it in the sand first, the
whole thing falls apart, right? You, you,
you,
you cannot take the same volume of rocks
and pebbles and sand and get it into
the jar and a which,
which visually, uh, from,
from an imagery standpoint, it is
very easy to understand. And, and, uh,
the,
the time audit though as you described,
is so important for people to do because
very often even your calendar is not a
good reflection of how you in
fact spend your time. And, uh,
if you look at say self
reporting in dietary studies
where they're observational
and people are going home and then coming
back and reporting every two weeks or
something like that.
If you,
if you ask people to estimate
their caloric consumption,
it's almost always like 30 to 40% off,
right? It's not a small difference. And
I think the same thing happens with time.
Uh, really, really routinely. Um, the,
the blocks of time, actually,
you know what I'm going to get,
I'm going to make a reading recommendation
and then I'm going to come back to
this name, which of course you're
going to be very familiar with,
but for people who really want to also
get a teaser for what you'll read more
about and the effective executive and
there's an essay, I might be getting it,
the headline slightly off, but you'll
be able to find it. Maker's schedule,
manager's schedule. Yep. Bye.
Bye. Paul Graham. And uh,
the legendary PG who are going to come
back to a, is a good place to start.
But I want to rewind the
clock for a second and ask
you why did you stop the sat
on my prep company?
So,
uh,
I started the sat prep company
in 2004 and then I, uh,
went back to school, finished my undergrad
and then a couple of things happen.
So I was still, I was, after graduation
I started working as an engineer at a,
a network security company.
Um,
and I was still moonlighting on the
s on Accolade, the sat prep company.
Um, but I found myself in a
situation where it was like,
it was just like harder and harder to
make progress on the sat prep company and
I wasn't really sure what was going on
because I just felt like it was just,
it took more and more willpower
to like pedal, uh, or I felt like,
I don't know whether it was because I
felt like I was peddling harder but not
getting anywhere or one way
or another, it just, it.
But over time it took a lot
more willpower to work on it.
And so I found myself procrastinating
with all these like side projects
and I mean now I recognize all
of this as burnout. Um, and,
and, and a positive. Uh, there aren't
a lot of good things about burnout,
but sometimes it can steer.
The positive element is consider your
attention to things that are more
worthwhile. Um, but then I was
worried cause I'm like, Oh my God,
I'm like so unproductive and I'm
getting a wallowing in this like guilt.
Um, I was raised Catholic, so like this
Catholic guilt of like not, you know,
I'm not working hard enough. This company
is not successful enough. All my Dah,
Dah, Dah, Dah, Dah, Dah. And it's
like totally not helpful. Um,
but, and so I'm like,
oh my God, am I broken?
Like I might not capable of working
hard, what's wrong with me? Um,
but then I would like,
well one good news,
I started working on this like poker Bot
that started and it
played with real money.
Like I like got past the security
on the poker client. This is six.
So I figured out how to like make all
that work and then watch kind of my
Frankenstein moment as the Bot comes to
life and starts playing on real poker
tables. And so this idea that you can have
poker bots was like totally false. Um,
but, and, and but I was possessed.
It was like kind of thing.
Was the WISC Frankenstein's monster
wedding? Well, I mean frank is,
the Frankenstein was like, not too,
not too smart in the beginning.
So like there's some [inaudible] it,
that's the thing starts moving
the mouse and playing cards,
playing the hand then gets
confused because it had,
there's some like obscure multiple split
pot or something that I just didn't
write the code to handle that situation.
So the thing crashes and folds your
aces and you're like, okay, awesome.
This is what AI looks like.
But it was scaring my
family because I was,
I was living in Boston but then we have
a little summer place in New Hampshire
and I was like, my family is like,
okay, you can come up this weekend,
we're all going to be at the
lake. And I'm like, okay.
And then I get to the lake and I'm start
unpacking my trunk and I've had like
three monitors and like all
these computers and I'm like,
I mean this is like a
little cottage on upon,
it's not set up to be
like mission control.
So I'm like putting monitors on
the stove and my parents are like,
what are you doing? They're kind of used
to me having all these side projects.
So they're just like, I
hope it's not illegal. Just,
um, unfortunately that side project had
to stop because of that, like the potent,
in fall of 2006, it became like, went
from like kind of borderline too,
like very illegal to do
online poker so that, um,
that project ended. But, um, but,
but so what's that about? Uh,
what I took from that was like,
well, first I'm like, I'm not broken.
I'm super capable of working hard.
It's just like,
I need to find something that
I'm really, I'm motivated by. Um,
and so that was a
relief. And then, um, uh,
and then along the way, so I, I
continued to work on the sat prep thing,
but then the kind of the founding
story of Dropbox was, um,
well I had to use,
well,
the founding sort of striped Dropbox
starts with forgetting my thumb drive and
going on the Chinatown bus, which I'll
get to. But, um, but before that I was,
I kept having these problems working
with my cofounder because, um,
are collaborating with them because
we didn't have an office. Well,
we bootstrapped the company,
so we didn't raise any money
and we didn't have an office.
We didn't work out at the same
place and we didn't have servers,
we didn't have anything. So we would
just like email stuff back and forth. Um,
and I had to work on multiple computers,
so I kept carrying around this thumb
drive and having these elaborate scripts
that would back up are
the sat prep company,
kind of all of our files to a server.
And then eventually I was like,
all right, well I want to, I,
I had graduated from
college is about 2006,
late 2006 a lot of my friends had
lived in New York and they were like,
you gotta come out. It's a
lot of fun here, you know,
just come out for the weekend. And I'm,
I have a dilemma because I'm like, well,
I need to get some stuff
done for my company,
but I also want to go to New York.
And I'm like,
maybe if I take the Chinatown
bus, uh, or if I ride the bus,
I can get, I can have four
and a half hours each way.
So then I'll have 10 hours.
10 hours should be enough time to do
what I need to do is, you know, you know,
the alert, elaborate rationalizations we
we come up with and so I'm like, okay,
I will fail if I take the bus. That's,
I'm, I'm greenlight to go to New York.
Then I get on the bus and
I've forgotten my thumb drive.
So and then crack problem. Yeah. Yeah.
Back to self flagellation I'm like, oh,
I can't, I'm like, I keep doing this.
I suck. You know, I'm not like I hate
my thumb drive. I'm like, I hate me. Um,
um, but I'm like, oh my God, I just
cannot deal with this problem. I'm like,
I know this is so stupid.
Like I'm so sick of like email,
like emailing myself a file.
Like what is the question for
which there is no question for us.
That's the right answer.
I'm like,
what did you think of the
physical equivalent of that?
Like taking an envelope,
putting something in it,
putting your own name in the to and from
putting it in the mailbox and getting
it back. I'm like, this is what we
do to like manage our files. Um,
uh, that carry on a thumb drive. All
the things we used to have to do.
And I'm like,
I never want to have this problem again.
So I on the bus,
um,
I open up the editor and started writing
some code in python that basically was
the seed that sprouted into Dropbox,
but it's weird and I was just like
totally possessed with that problem. Um,
because I'm an engineer, I'm
an engineer by upbringing. Um,
my favorite classes at school other than
some of the stuff we've talked about
was, or like algorithms,
distributed systems, um, you know,
and I found myself at a
crossroads where I'm like, look,
I love standardized tests as
much as any human possibly can,
I guess.
But it was a couple of things happen.
So one is I like pause. I'm like,
okay, I'm working on this company.
I'm kind of burning out.
Um,
part of why is because I
thought about it like, okay,
even if all of my dreams come through
and like everything we hope for happens
with this sat prep company,
then I'm like, then what?
Then then what? And I'm like,
I'm like King of sat prep.
Right?
And there's nothing,
I mean I think that's fine and like
people need help with these things,
but I'm like,
that's not what I want to do.
I'm just picturing this kind
of like cardboard crown.
And I'm like, and that's only
if everything goes well. Oh,
that's like if all of our
dreams come true. So I'm like,
I need to do something else.
Um,
and so I ended up with these side projects
and then found myself getting totally
obsessed with a first to poker Bot,
but then even more so with Dropbox.
And so sometimes it's hard it, you
know, like how do you deal with burnout?
How do you know if you're
doing the right thing? And,
cause these are really hard questions.
I mean for me sort of listening,
sometimes a lot of
procrastination is unhealthy,
but sometimes that little voice is
leading you in a much better direction.
So I want to serve, I want to
bring this back to the dot, dot,
dot that I left after Paul Graham.
Uh,
and we can certainly go in any
possible direction you want to take it.
But for people who don't know,
Paul Graham, maybe you could,
maybe you could describe Paul Graham's
certainly as close to a Demi God as one
can probably get among many,
many young entrepreneurs and older
entrepreneurs in silicon valley.
Who is Paul Graham?
What is y Combinator?
And can you describe your
first meeting with Paul Graham?
Yes. Um, so Paul Graham
is best known as the, uh,
is one of the founders of y Combinator.
So they are,
which is an incubator for startups.
They've,
and they were our first investors and
they also invested in a lot of great
companies, including, um, Airbnb,
stripe, uh, a lot of them.
And, uh, Paul was before
starting my Combinator,
he had written, uh, he, he
was an entrepreneur himself,
so he started coming home via web back
in the.com or the the first.com boom and
sold it.
And then he had a lot of
really provocative and
insightful essays on startups
that gained a big following.
Um,
and he was also one of
the creators, um, um,
or at least was very early in
the conversation around, uh,
using a Bayesian methods using this
kind of math to do spam filtering.
So he's also one of the originals are one
of the architects or at least involved
in that community of people who have
figured out how to get rid of spam. Um,
and that's actually how
I first heard about him,
but then he started writing about
startups and then ran this experiment that
became my Combinator.
Um,
but it was actually called the summer
founders program when I was digging
through some old email it because, um, I,
this was the precursor to y Combinator.
Uh,
I applied with my sat prep
company to that and was rejected.
Um, but then managed to get
into y Combinator a couple
of years later. So, um,
so I guess the first virtual meeting
of applying to be funded, uh,
didn't go well. Um, the first in person
meeting was probably, oh wait, hold on,
hold on, pause. Why didn't, why didn't
the virtual meeting go well? Well,
we didn't really officially meet.
It was just sort of like,
if it was like a college admissions
thing [inaudible] we, you, you,
it's open application. Anybody who wants
to submit an application kit for, uh,
for the summer founders program,
which is basically,
it was like the same thing as y Combinator
to like you get a little bit of money
and they'll all come together. Um, it was
like sort of y Combinator version one.
Um, but I applied and didn't get in
and I was super disappointed. Um,
so that didn't go well. And
then, but a couple years later,
I wanted to apply again with Dropbox
and this is skipping ahead a little bit,
but, um, I had,
so I had the idea for Dropbox,
um,
started working on it and I want to do
YC because a good friend of mine or for
for many reasons, but in a, in another
friend of mine, this Guy Adam Smith,
uh, no relation, um, it was one
of her friends from college. Uh,
he did YC in 2006 and had an awesome
experience and I had like a front row seat
to that and saw how
much fun they're having.
And then their company was just in like
a much faster trajectory because of YC
and I'm like, oh my God, I want
something like that. Um, but then I have,
so I started thinking about
applying for YC with Dropbox.
Um,
and one of the good things about coming
from college admissions is you sort of
learn how these admissions processes work.
Um,
and YC was not really that different.
You have a lot of people
applying for a few spots. Um,
and so in addition to getting the
scores and the grades and everything,
one of the things you can do is try to
stand out and do something kind of unique.
And so I'm like,
all right,
well maybe to get in
to help me get into Yc,
I'll try to put a video out
about how Dropbox works.
Um, and y Combinator also had their
own, they had just started this new,
this new site called Hacker News,
um,
which is kind of like reddit
first startup news. Um, and,
uh, and I'm like, what is I'm buying?
I thought, I'm like, I had an,
I had a hunch and I'm like, what do you,
what do I, what does Paul do all day?
I think he probably
does what most of us do,
which is just hit refresh on hacker
news all the time. So I'm like,
maybe you have to put
a video on hacker news.
Maybe I can get in front of the dean of
admissions here to get Paul's attention
and then go from there. It actually
worked. Um, so I made and, and,
and I was a concept from a book that I
had read on that roof called guerrilla
marketing,
which is like how do you get attention
and you and users for your product if you
have no Jay Levinson, 11 cent
or something like that. Yeah,
something like that. It's like, how do you
do that when you have no money? So, uh,
and, and so they're like
all these, so there,
it's the tactic of putting a video on
hacker news or creating a viral video is
that that was a seed that was planted by
reading guerrilla marketing. Um, and so,
but I made a screencast or just like a,
like a three minute demo
of how Dropbox works.
Cause like I wasn't
ready to ship the code,
but I wanted some feedback and
I wanted to get into YC. Um,
and that video both got me into
YC and it got me a cofounder. Um,
but I didn't know that at the
time. So, uh, coming back to,
so then what happened with
this meeting with Paul?
So I put the video on hacker news.
It hits the top of hacker news for
multiple days. It's a long time.
Talked about the top of hacker news APP.
That can't happen anymore because for
a bunch of reasons. But it was like,
I was pretty happy about that.
Um, and then, uh, I'm like, okay,
this is so far the plan seems
to be working. I'm just like,
keep hitting refresh on my inbox. I'm
like, maybe I wonder if Paul has seen it.
And then Lo and behold, I get an email
from Paul Graham saying like, Hey,
it looks pretty cool. Um,
but you need a cofounder.
Cause they did it,
especially at the time.
They didn't like single founders applying.
And I didn't have a cofounder yet.
This was, this was before I
met a rush. Um, so I was like,
Oh God. Um, because the PR, the
only problem was I agreed with him.
The only problem was the application
deadline was, had already passed.
I already applied. Um, and the
interviews were in like two weeks.
And so I needed a cofounder in two
weeks, which is like saying like, Hey,
I know you're not dating anyone
but you need to get married by.
Right. Uh, and so, uh,
hilarity ensued. But, uh,
but then I was, I can't, I flew
out to San Francisco. I'm like,
I'm like trying to shake the trees
for any cofounder candidates.
I hadn't thought of it because
for one reason or another,
all of my close friends and
people that would have been the,
the folks that I would have leaned on,
like at the timing wasn't good.
They didn't want to do it,
whatever else. And so, um, but I,
I found, uh, another friend of mine,
I was actually getting managed to get
a friend of mine interested out in San
Francisco. Um, but he's like,
okay, I'm interested. I don't know,
but I want to know what PG thinks before
I make a decision. So I'm like, okay,
great. Um, and I'm like, it's a Tuesday.
My flight is a Tuesday at like 1:00 PM.
My flight back to Boston leads
it like 10 or 11. So I'm like,
oh actually wait, this is, YC
has its dinners on Tuesdays.
Maybe I can just like drive
down to mountain view and
just like pitch Paul maybe
that will
visit bar. I like fly
down in one on one. Um,
and like the plan was working pretty well.
I got it.
I got to Yc, I went in the
office. It was as expected.
People were just chilling and kind of,
um, there was some downtime. And so,
um,
and so I go knock on,
or like I go, I go to Paul's office
and sure enough he's in there.
He's just challenge my, Hey
Paul, do you have a minute?
Um, I just want to, you know,
I just want to show you something I'm
working on. And he's like, no, I'm busy.
And I'm like, okay, look, we bought, I'm
like, I, I can almost see your screen.
I know you're just like hitting reef.
You're just like reading hacker
news right now. Actually busy. Um,
but it's like awkward. So I step
outside and I talked to Jessica, um,
who as an, uh, his,
his partner at in cofounding YC
together. And, and, and his wife.
Um, and I talked to Jessica,
I'm like, Hey, look,
Jessica and I had met Jessica
before, so I'm like, Jessica,
I'm really sorry to bother you guys.
I just have a cofounder who
was like looking for some
feedback from Paul to make
his cofounder decision. You know, I
got a flight back in like four hours.
I swear I'll, I'll, I won't take
more than 60 seconds of Paul's time.
Do you think it's okay if, um,
if I go in there and she's like,
oh, we've got drew of
course, like, no problem.
Like Paul's not doing anything
just like he'll, it'll be fine.
So I go back in there
and
it's like detonation,
it's like I still like three words
and Paul's like, no, he's like,
I'm not going to see your stupid demo.
The whole reason we have an application
process so that randos like,
you don't just like show up here
and bother us. It's like, no,
please leave. And so I'm like, okay,
thanks Jessica. Thanks Paul. Like,
Ooh, like my friend that's, I'm like,
this is not going to be good.
And like it was a rough,
rough returned to San Francisco.
So needless to say,
the cofounders situation did not work
out. You were like there, Paul's,
Paul's thinking about it. Let
me get back to you. I did,
I did meet with the dean of admissions.
He just thinks I'm an asshole.
So that was, I think he's,
I think he's coming around.
Get back to that was a tough plane
ride home. Um, but as good training,
like this is, you know, this,
this is you gotta this is like the new
normal if you're starting a company. Um,
so let me, let me just hit pause
for one second. What were you,
what were you saying to
yourself on the way back?
Like what was the self talk on the
plane ride back? I was like, I have,
I could not have like eff this
up any worse if I had tried.
Um, cause like now and I'm
co founder and I'm like,
I might've been able to
get in if I just like,
hadn't like maximally pissed off Paul.
Okay.
Anyway, now I have no cofounder,
no YC and probably know company.
Um, and like two weeks left
to like resolve this, um,
may or maybe a week left to resolve.
But anyway, not a lot of time. Um,
so it was bad. Yeah. I was like,
I don't really see how this all
kind of lives happily ever after.
So then what happened?
So then,
but my kind of shaking the trees in
San Francisco did help. So I met, it.
Turned out I met a guy
named Kyle convoked,
um, who I'd met at the Mit entrepreneurs
club. So he's an MIT student.
He dropped out here.
He had just dropped out to do Justin TV,
which became twitch. Um, and then
Kyle then later started cruise,
which did degrades Kyle
Kyle has done well. Um,
and then I was complaining
to Kyle and like, hey Kyle,
like I need a cofounder. I,
you know, is there anyone
you'd recommend? And he,
he recommended me to a,
it turned out that Kyle and Raj
were four made cities campus at Mit.
Um, and so he's like, Oh, you should talk
to a rush. And then a day or two later,
I got an email from [inaudible]
saying, hey, um, he was like, uh,
he was a senior Undergrad at MIT
computer science student. Um,
and, uh, and he was like, hey, I got
this email from rush and say like, Hey,
I saw your video on hacker news.
And Kyle said,
you're looking for a cofounder.
You know, maybe we should talk.
And then it was kind of insane.
Like we met in the student center.
Um, maybe we got coffee one more
time and then he drops out of school.
Um, he's like a senior, he drops
off with a semester left. You know,
I was thinking this is going to be
like a process. Right. As I mentioned,
I talked to his parents and like reassure
them if I notice like we hang out for
like two hours and then
he then like come then we,
the two of us commit to like spending
most of our waking lives together for the
foreseeable future.
I don't think either of us really
understood that at the time. Um,
fortunately it all has worked
out great. But, um, so, but,
but against all odds. So
our osh and I team up, um,
I think Paul forgot about his meeting
with me or didn't like put the two
together. So we, we did our
interview, um, and we got into Yc,
so, and it was funny cause
like we were doing the white,
the interview were milling around waiting
for who? We go down in the morning,
we go get lunch. Um, we
come back to the car,
are our car got broken into on
our laptops, got stolen. Oh God.
But fortunately all of
our stuff was on Dropbox,
so we were like patient zero for all this.
And then we got the happy phone
call from Paul saying, Hey,
we want to fund you guys. And
ended up, I mean, I dunno, it was,
it was nuts though.
So I don't know if this has changed,
but for some period of time,
uh, I think it's probably still the case,
but, but you could correct me if I'm
wrong.
I mean,
Dropbox was far and away the
most successful investment
that y Combinator had
ever made, uh, ended up, I mean,
certainly Dropbox has
done incredibly well.
At what points did you go to
go to Paul's office and knock,
knock. Hey Paul. Like in
brackets now we're friends
by any chance?
Do you remember when I came in daring
Tuesday on a Tuesday not too long ago,
Dah,
Dah.
Did you ever bring that up with him or
did he learn about it through some other
means?
I like to remind them about it.
Every camp, every year to first.
He's like totally embarrassed.
Like he didn't, like,
he didn't put any of these
things together. He didn't
know, he didn't remember it.
Um, he's like, I was so awful at this
app. So the, the mostly it's just they,
they both Paul and Jessica to turn like
bright red and they don't like to talk
about it, which is like why I like to
keep poking at it every now and then.
It's all, I mean, it's all good. I
would have done this course him. Well,
he did tell you I'm busy, right?
Yeah, I was super obnoxious, but
some was dropped. It was Dropbox, the
original name of the company. Yeah,
it was. Wow. So, so just from day
one you had the name that stuck.
Oh, pretty good. Getting the domain.
It was get dropbox.com getting
the dropbox.com domain name was,
oh my God, that was a,
that was the journey. Um,
so there was, I don't know, I'm like,
I'm like starting to shake a
little bit going. I don't know.
I don't know how illuminating
this the story is, but it had no,
let's talk about it people, I mean
people run into this stuff. I'm sure.
I'm sure we can. I'm sure we
can pull some lessons from that.
So I I remember get Dropbox.
So ration, I fell like,
so the,
the,
the name Dropbox actually
the behind the music version,
like the story behind the name is also
probably unintuitive or like not what
you'd expect. So, um, you asked what am I
like, what was that like in high school?
Um, and the answer is like, basically
he's a huge nerd who likes computer games.
And that's true. Uh, one of the things
we would do is we'd all bring our,
uh,
w we would like a bunch of friends and
I would bring our computers to someone's
house and we'd play games.
And, um, so back in the day,
these things were called land parties. Um,
they are about as cool as they camp. Um,
and uh, and, and you know,
you all show up and played,
you play Til Sunrise
and, and, um, and so on.
But you bring a bunch of people together
and often someone doesn't have the,
the right maps or the right
patch or the right whatever.
And so we had a convention,
like you've just create a folder called
your Dropbox that's shared and writeable
by anyone. Um, and that's how
he would exchange files. Um,
so that people could play games.
Um, and then it's, I remember this,
it was like Christmas 2006.
I'm trying to come up with a name for
Dropbox nor didn't have a name then. I,
uh, the initial name, I had like some, uh,
what the name before I was dizzy,
photoshopping a logo.
Is it initial iteration of it
was folder anywhere which catchy.
Catchy, yes. Which just was,
which was probably the first indication
that I had a brilliant future in
marketing and for this.
And then some like in Photoshop trying
to make a logo for folder anywhere.
And I'm like,
I'm like,
of course the probably the logo was
like a literal folder or something like
totally inane.
And then I start and I'm like,
and I, you know, believe it or not fold
or anywhere.com was actually available.
So I, I was the proud owner
of older anywhere that com.
Then I realized that I did a search and
I found that there's a company called
files anywhere and I was like,
no,
like I can't, I that's, it's like I can't,
now, I can't name it folder anywhere.
And so I'm,
I'm sort of,
I'm on aim talking to one of my friends
from high school and I'm like, God,
I don't know what to call this thing,
you know, folder anywhere it's taken.
Like, maybe I should just, you know,
maybe maybe I should call it Dropbox,
like from the, you know, from, from high
school or from land parties and he's like,
okay, whatever. And then, um,
and then I Dropbox like how not available.
Uh,
so I got get dropbox.com but then,
um,
so we just lived with get dropbox.com
for awhile. I tried to you,
you can sometimes look up who owns a
domain and then contact them. And so I,
I actually did, I amended that I managed
to give the guy a call, um, and I'm like,
Hey, are you dropbox.com? You
know, are you, are you using
it? And the guy was like,
uh, yes, I'm using it for
a project. I'm like, okay,
well do you have any interest
in like selling it or, you know,
coming up with some kind of arrangement?
He's like, no. I'm like, okay, cool.
So that's February,
2007 and then,
then we then, then we get distracted
with the whole getting into Yc,
finding a cofounder, all that
doing YC, and then I land in,
then we moved to San Francisco
in September and I'm like,
we really need to get this domain
name. Um, and unfortunately our ration,
I had totally fallen in love with it.
So like we weren't really,
we kind of only had one
plan. Um, by the way, that's,
that's called a great, uh,
negotiating position. Yeah. Awesome.
About as well as you'd
expect. So we, I'm like, well,
since the fluffiness Zipcar and show up
at someone's house worked so well the
first time,
we're going to do it again.
So it turned out the guy
lived in Pleasanton, um,
and he was an entrepreneur.
Here's someone who like nearby,
who should be sympathetic to our cause
at to some extent. Um, and I'm like,
and I call him and I'm like,
how's that project going?
Because there's obviously no project in
and he's just kind of being difficult.
Um, and so I'm like, I'm
like, okay, God damn it.
We get off the phone and I'm like,
are Ashley's,
let's just like show
up at this guy's house.
Let's just see what happens.
Um, so jumping into other car,
we go to the,
that we've dropped when they go to the
like the the corner store and get their
like most expensive bottle of
$20 champagne. We could get, uh,
get as a car and go to his house
and um, it's like nine at night.
So I don't know, for some,
this seemed like a good idea at the time.
So we show up then and then he was kind
of, I think he was kind of shocked,
kind of amused. It's like lets
us in. Um, we have a suite,
we start talking and he's
like, we're like, hey look,
you know, we're, we're, we're,
we're pretty serious about this thing
we're doing. You know, we'd love, um,
you know,
if,
if it's true that you're not actually
doing anything with the domain, you know,
like help, help us understand
what you're trying to accomplish.
[inaudible] noxious way.
Just like, you know,
but at least consider this alternative
where you know, we use dropbox.com.
You know,
we've got some really good folks who
are excited about this in involved,
whether that's y Combinator,
we just gotten funding from sequoia,
our first venture capital investor
who one of the best in the world.
And so we're like, oh you, oh you, oh,
you told him that? Yeah. All right. Yeah,
that's really building
up our leverage here.
So this would be called hemorrhaging
leverage all at the same time.
You know, these, these, uh,
the frameworks don't completely account
for everything cause if you don't,
if you don't actually help them understand
why they should be interested and you
hold all your cards to the vest and
nothing happens and that's what we can
experience over the last seven
months. So we're like, um, okay,
so like at least get sketch out a case
that a reasonable person would look at
and be interested in. So,
um, and then he's like,
um, cool. Uh, it's interesting,
I got to talk to a friend.
Um, and you know, why don't you,
why don't we touch base soon?
And I'm like, I'm like, great. Well,
it was like Friday. I'm like, whoa.
It was like a Friday night,
I think. And I'm like, well,
we'll be back on Monday. Um,
and we're, we're in the ride back going
over the bay bridge. And I'm like,
Holy Shit, we might actually
be able to get this thing,
like this guy has been
impenetrable and so difficult.
Like we're both kind of in awe and just
like, this is such a positive thing.
So we go back on Monday and he's
just like, Yep, thought about it,
not interested. Thanks. Bye.
And we're like, are you kidding?
Is this for real? Like, no. I'm like,
I'm like, where's this going to go?
Are you going to like, are you going to
bequeath this domain to your children?
Like, what the hell? Um,
but he was just like
totally wouldn't budge.
And so that was a much sadder drive back.
So then this guy,
and then there's just kind of nothing
for a couple of years or for a year. Um,
and then we launched drop out. We
put a, we launched Dropbox publicly,
um,
and then all these confused
people start going to dropbox.com,
uh, and, and presumably start trying to
get, and they wanted to get into the Beta.
So this is, this is later in the
air. So the, the, the, and the,
so that he starts getting all these emails
from people, I think probably March,
2008, um, who were looking to
get into the Dropbox data. Um,
and then he, he does God, he,
and I'll end the story in a reasonable
amount of time, but we like,
so he,
he then he kind of goes dark,
he puts a privacy shield up on the domain,
then puts up an ad words landing page.
So like dropbox.com, like it was a, no,
it went from like a go daddy parking
page to like a Google adsense for domains
page. Um, which was a problem
because then we're like, oh my God,
now this guy is like totally cashing in.
Like it's basically
you go to Dropbox icon.
It was basically ad words for all
of our competitors. Oh God. Um,
and so I'm just thinking of like,
I'm like,
what the hell are we gonna do about this?
Like our investors think we're
idiots for not changing the name.
We're doing all these like pointless
and branding exercises that,
um, did not go well, like to
try to find an alternate name.
So I'm just like, oh my God, look
what, what are we going to do?
And the answer was read the Federal
Copyright Code and a trademark code.
Um,
and I became kind of an
expert in Cyber Trademark Law.
I got an armchair expert in this stuff
and it turns out you can't just like get
a domain from someone for no reason.
Like you can't just be like, oh,
you're not using it, so therefore it's
mine anymore. You can can be like, oh,
you're not using that
land to give it to me.
But it is also illegal for
someone to intentionally confused,
um, uh, confused customer can
confuse your customers. So,
um, I can't just like say
that were, um, you know,
I can't sell paper teller tell or I
can't sell like Kleenex with three e's to
confuse people or whatever.
So like intentionally confusing
consumers is a problem. Um,
and we had another whole odyssey
trying to get the Dropbox trademark,
which aisle that's not as interesting, but
I'm like, we had a problem what we did,
we didn't actually have the
registered trademark either. Um,
but he was now making money
from infringing on our
common law trademark rights.
And so I'm working with this
crazy trademark like was
like trademark and domain
attorney. And so we sue him for
federal, for trademark infringement.
Um, and so that got his attention. Um,
and, and which we would not
have done it. Like we're not,
we weren't just trying to push
him around. I mean, he was really,
he was sure trying to
profit off of confusing our
customers. So we were for sure.
Dot on our high horse
after that. Um, and I mean,
that was a comical whole experience, but
eventually he's like, okay, okay, okay.
Um, you know, all, all like, let's, this
is, there's no point to have this lawsuit.
You know, I'll give you guys are, I'll
tell you guys the domain, I'm like, okay,
well we can offer use stock or cash.
She's like, I'll just take cash. Um,
so we paid him 300 grand,
got the domain live.
I mean that was such a,
like sending that first email from
dropbox.com to Paul and Jessica was a huge
triumph. Um, but what's even it,
I offer,
we offered him stock at that like at w
would have been at the seed round the
most God worth like multiple hundreds
of millions of dollars today.
Oh Man.
I think what you can
take away from this, it's like there's
just no manual for that, right?
You got to kind of wing it.
And there were a lot of things
that are the equivalent.
Even today I've just kind of getting in
the zip car with a bottle of champagne
and hoping for the best and, and um, you
know, sometimes we get really good cards.
Sometimes you get really bad cards, but
you just got to kind of roll with it. Um,
and so, um, between finding a
cofounder, getting the domain, each,
each of those is definitely,
those are definitely memorable
points along the journey.
Well, we were chatting a bit before we
started recording about the psychological
aspects of say,
prepping for starting a company.
And I want to tie that to a
company you mentioned earlier,
which is reddit and see you mentioned
that hacker news is sort of read it for
the,
the computer science slash hacker subset.
Rhett and I remember having Alexis the
cofounder on this podcast and he told me
about meeting really early on
with an executive at Yahoo.
They were really excited.
They went in and they shared their
numbers in the executive said wow,
if something along the lines of Oh my God,
you're just a rounding error for Yahoo.
And it was so insulting
that Alexis took like
you are a rounding error,
I think it was and put it on the wall
in the office to motivate. Right.
But that's, that is one of
several different responses
that that are possible.
Right. I mean there are,
there are certainly people
who would be crushed by that.
It could be the end. Uh, and I don't,
I don't remember exactly
where this quote is from,
but I want to talk about when
this came out and how you,
what the self talk was. So the, he, uh,
okay. This, there's an article being
written about Dropbox and I
think the quote was quote,
fortunately the Dropbox
founders are too stupid to know.
Everyone's already tried
this and quote. Yeah. Uh,
so when did that happen and how did you
and anyone else involved respond to it?
Yeah, so that was very early. Um,
I would say it was probably
within the first year and, uh,
probably the most, well, I think
what happens is you'll get,
I mean,
I just think that even back to that
first video that I put it on Hacker News,
a lot of the, actually a lot
of the commentary was positive.
People like I would use
something like this, it's good.
Like, and it was really, um,
uh, and that was really encouraging.
So it's all on the one hand,
half the peanut gallery saying
that the other half is saying like,
listing all these reasons why it's been
tried before and won't work. Um, that,
and then even if it does
work, like Microsoft, Google,
everybody is going to kill us.
Um,
and here's why it's never been a business
and here are all these other ones that
have never succeeded at. And the things
that I agreed with them, I was like,
yeah, you're probably right. Like, I
don't really see how we survive as,
I mean in 2007 I don't see how
we kind of make it through,
you know,
to mount doom,
little plucky band of,
uh, the two of us. Um,
so,
and then invariably every investor we
talked to would raise similar concerns.
So the, the, the feedback is
all pretty negative. So, um,
it's easy to say like, oh, just ignore
it all, but you, you kind of have to,
you have to be balanced.
So on the, on the one hand,
we did get encouraging feedback in
the beginning, so people were like,
drop this as cool. I will use this.
It sounds great. Um, you know,
and I knew that I needed it and then I
wasn't like trying to create $1 billion
company. I was trying to
just like solve the problem.
And so I think setting your sights
low in the beginning ironically,
can be helpful because you're not
putting so much pressure on yourself.
I was just like, look,
if I show the cool thing,
it'll be one of this is just another side
project and a number of side projects
and like, let me not suffocate
it by putting all these
crazy expectations on it.
Um, so I think that's pretty important.
Um, and then people are like, oh,
when did he know it was a
success? It's like, well,
it was sort of a different point. It, it,
it was like the goalpost for success
kept successively moving back.
So even just having a video was a big
milestone in launching a private beta was
a big milestone and there were
a bunch of milestones, but,
so it was sort of a continuous
project process more than like, oh,
is this one moment in time? Um, but yeah,
there were people who had very good
arguments about why this wasn't gonna be
successful. And that's why I think, um,
you have to have,
you have to sort of have alternate,
you have to have both
thick skin and thin skin,
I guess to have kind of get that
balance right. Because if you just have,
if you just ignore all of the feedback
and dismiss it all, then you're PR,
you're probably going to have some
kind of blind spot and you're gonna,
you're gonna miss some
important information. So, um,
just because they came, but,
but just because they came to that
conclusion doesn't mean that their
assumptions were all correct.
And that's why you also need to have
enough thick skin to know when to like,
um, when to be a little bit dismissive
or not listen to everything.
Um,
uh,
and part of what helps with that is having
conviction and conviction that comes
from being able to think
from first principles, um,
and pay less attention
to people's conclusions.
Let the outputs of people's conclusions
as much as the inputs into those
conclusions. So what does that
mean? Well, people said that, okay,
the Dropbox is not gonna be successful
because if people try to in a million
times, um, and that is,
that is true in anybody who that's
like factually true. It's not,
you can't debate that. Um, but that
would have been true for mobile.
Like every phone,
every mobile thing before the iPhone
or every mobile software company,
every APP like was a total failure
before the iPhone world changes.
Suddenly it's the right time. And so, um,
if you study history of technology or
history business, you realize, okay,
that that argument is not in
and of itself. Um, causal. Um,
so the, the, what you want to answer is
like a why is that incorrect? It's like,
well, actually, um, there, there
are a lot of good ideas that are,
are bad ideas for awhile
because the timing is wrong.
But then at the time he becomes right
because of some discontinuity in tech and
like then,
and what's like the innovator's
dilemma or others will illustrate that.
And so if you really understand these,
if you understand that that's why it's
important to build these mental models
because you were like,
all right,
this is my framework for how the world
works and I keep refining it. Um,
what these people are missing.
The key conclusion from that,
that just because something has
happened like has failed before,
it doesn't mean it will always feel in
the future, can still fail. But, um,
but that kind of conviction came from an
understanding or a belief and a f and a
worldview and framework of like,
here's how,
here's how I think business
works or here's how to think
about an idea like ours.
Um, so, but that said, it's not.
So I think there's a,
how do you receive advice and how do
you sort of develop first principles
thinking,
which we talked about,
but then like that doesn't make it feel
any better when people that like your
idea socks and you're going to fail,
um,
or worse that like you are
stupid or you're an elite. Yeah.
At Super Ad Hominem, right?
Um, yeah, people are not.
So, first of all, I think you have to
have a sense of like this is normal.
I'm like, do it. Just don't take it too
personal. Like, cause that's the thing,
you know, you want to take
it, you do want to take,
you want to receive the feedback and
like try to extract the kernel of that's
useful from it but not feel obligated to,
to accept the whole thing.
Um,
I think more broadly you have to,
whether it's getting criticism
or just a lot of the things,
I think one of the harder things about
running the company in general was I just
remember being in the beginning
being like, oh my God.
Like all right now we,
uh,
like sequoia has decided to invest in,
in our comp against the odds.
Now Sequoia has decided to invest there.
They're writing us a check for $1 million.
I hope they realize that.
Like I've never, I've not,
I haven't really done this before. And
like, Oh God, like that million dollar,
it's great to kind of cash that check.
But whoa man,
they're going to be looking for
that money back at some point. Like,
what are we going to do? Um, and
so that's not, that wasn't the,
I mean there were probably a lot of things
going on in my head at the time, but,
and then like, oh my God, I've never
really built a successful company for,
I don't, I've never manage
people really, you know,
the idea of Dropbox being at a hundred
person company is like terrifying.
Like I'm,
this treadmill is just going to go faster
and faster until like I'm violently
thrown off of it. Like, how am
I going to deal with that? Um,
and, and a lot of me also felt
like, okay, well I'll just be like,
build the company until it's
like successful enough or
makes enough money where
I just don't have to worry about money
anymore. And then I had like, uh,
like as soon as I get to that, I don't
know, this was like some kind of theory.
I'm like, all right, as soon as
I get to that level of success,
I'll just stop and like, just
when will screw it up. Um,
but then interestingly that the fat
goalpost kept moving back and moving back
and moving back because I think it's,
it's never really been about the money,
but you can read in the y Combinator
application, like that's now public.
We put that out there and I'm
like, I would, I would like,
I would if I had $1 million after taxes,
F for six months of work,
I consider that a pretty
good deal. Um, so, um,
so, but, but, but, but more on the,
the, the, the more I'm just like,
what do you do when you're like, oh my
God, this is like pretty uncomfortable.
I've never done anything like this
before. Um, I might screw it up. You need,
so your instinct will to be to,
um,
run away from that feeling and what you
need to learn to do is run towards it
because that's just going to keep, keep
happening, keep happening. Like, you know,
we're going to drive a show up at
this guy's house. I don't know.
Maybe we'll get arrested. I don't
know. But we're going to do it.
I don't think that's the best example. Uh,
there's so many things where it's like,
you just gotta Kinda figure it
out and keep going. Um, and Ben,
one of the great things from
that that Ben wrote in his book,
the hard thing about hard things is the
hardest part of being a CEO is managing
your psychology. Um, and I didn't
really know what that meant at the time.
I think I have a much better sense now.
So I think first thing is getting
comfortable with being uncomfortable, um,
because, and, and you think about
principles like Ray Dalio, his book,
he's like pain plus reflection
equals progress. Uh,
people love the progress
part or they love growth,
but they don't love the pain part and
they don't bother to do the reflection
part. So, um, uh,
so understanding that that isn't in the
sort of zooming out and understanding,
like depersonalized it, it's
like, it's not really you.
This is just like the process of growth.
It will be painful or think
of your journey as more of
an adventure rather than
like a final exam where you have to get
everything right and you only got one
shot. Um, I think that's,
that's pretty important.
And then second is all right,
you have to, now it's, it's,
everybody likes the idea of
growth and pushing yourself,
but you also have to take
care of yourself. Like, um,
you have to find ways to metabolize
stress and avoid burnout.
Um,
and for some reason people just,
they just use the one tool of like pushing
themselves harder and then they break.
Um, and you know, you
wouldn't do that to your car.
You wouldn't do that with
like a musical instrument.
So why would you do that
to yourself? Right. So,
um, just to, just to pause for a second,
like I recall very distinctly every time
we've stayed at the same hotel or been
at the same event and
I've gone to the gym,
I've almost always seen you in the gym.
Uh,
I mean it seems like you have,
just as a component of that,
a physical practice to care
for the machine, so to speak.
Yeah. I wouldn't say I'm the best
like athlete by any stretch, but I,
but it's really important that you have
to do enough so that you don't break
down. Um, and so, and, and you've got
to figure out what that is for you. And,
um, and I know that's something
you really care about and, and the,
the advice that you have to offer your
readers is gonna be a much better than
whatever advice I have a,
but you need to do something,
some kind of routine and stick to
it. Um, but just the basics of the,
I think some of the stoop, the dumbest
advice that people get is like, you know,
not sleeping or wearing like,
or just pursuing this idea that that
successful people somehow work like 70,
80 hour weeks and that's the norm. Um,
there are a number of problems with that.
First,
it's like usually not true.
It's usually more of an indication that
person's either lack of awareness about
where they're spending their time or
a lack of effectiveness if they need.
Um, if their only tool in the shed
is like work more hours. Right.
Because just think about that,
like, you know, there that that is,
that has a ceiling in terms of how much
of an advantage that can give you. Like,
yes, you want to work hard. Um,
but if you're only advantages,
like being able to work 20% more hours
than someone who's merely very committed,
then you're not going to have outsized
results. And you also, I mean there's,
so there's, I have a, I have a,
I think this meme that
people that successful people
work a hundred hour weeks
or something is, is both
false and super harmful. Um,
most of the, most, the most successful
people I know actually work. I mean they,
they've crunched times
where they're super busy,
but they otherwise have a workweek
that looks more normal than not. Um,
and so that, that was something
I didn't realize when I was,
when I was starting out. But the
basics of sleep, eating well, self,
self care, exercise,
putting it on your calendar,
not just wishful thinking and hoping
it'll sort of happen in the spare moments.
Like if you can't see, um,
these things on your case,
if you can't see your
priorities in your calendar,
if you can't see your gym time on the
calendar, it doesn't exist. I'm totally,
so, uh, and then,
and then I think like self awareness,
there's probably a lot more
we could talk about how to,
how to metabolize stress
and avoid burnout.
But I think having that
taken care of the basics,
like having a good foundation and setting
healthy boundaries is pretty important.
And having a sustainable workload,
um,
the self awareness is pretty important
and being willing to like shine a hard
light on yourself, um, and
embracing that. So for me,
coaching has been super helpful.
A coaching meaning you have
like an executive coach.
I've had different ones over
time. Um, and, and, and,
and really like I go through the
experience, I'm like, Oh God,
I'll give this a shot. So
my friends have had, um,
I have spoken positively about it.
Um, but it's a little, it's um,
well I'll say this first part.
I remember my first coaching
experience and like getting,
they do the three 60 and then you sit
down and you do your review of your
results. So, sorry to pause.
The three 60 for people who don't
know is where you have any superiors,
peers, employees, et Cetera,
people who know you really well,
interviewed about your
strengths, weaknesses and so
on. Would you, is that fair?
Is that fair to say? Yeah. Well you get
all this feedback from all of these,
you know, everybody you were closely work
with, so it's kind of overwhelming, um,
cause you get a lot of it.
Um, and it's not all good.
So, uh, and actually to this day,
like opening those documents and like
reading all the free 60 feedback is one of
the most painful like human
experiences you can have. Um,
maybe that's a little hyperbolic but,
but it's not fun. It's at least not fun.
It's not something I look forward
to. Um, but it's important. So, um,
because you need to know,
like it's much better to just like know
and being able to do something about it.
Like Act. Then Ben, Ben's been a
great friend and mentor and he's like,
he was reflecting, he told me a quote
that one of his mentors told him,
which is that God gave us all weaknesses.
It's a blessing to find out about them.
Yeah. You know, sobering. You know? Um,
uh, but so, but, but I went through the,
I just remember my first coaching
experience briefly, like, you know,
sit you down and they're like,
first page is usually like,
here are your strengths. And I'm like,
okay. He's like, my coach was like,
you are really good. You really,
really care about people.
You love building great relationships. And
I'm like, Yep, okay. Yeah, that sounds,
that sounds good. Um, you're really
creative. You like new ideas. I'm like,
all right, I'm enjoying this
coaching thing so far. He's like,
you're really comfortable in chaos.
Like it doesn't bother you that this
stuff is like so crazy. I'm like, Yup.
It's like, okay, Duh, Duh, Duh. And then
flip to the next page. All right. Now,
like it's never weaknesses,
development areas. That's right.
Or operating opportunities are to
improve it. So something like, all right,
let's hear about some
opportunities. Um, he's like,
you are really conflict
avoidant. Um, you don't, uh,
make hard people decisions. Uh,
people don't know what you do,
but like where they stand.
I'm like, okay. He's like, ah,
you're unreliable. You drop,
you drop balls, um, uh,
you're not paying enough attention to
the things that are important. I'm like,
okay. And he's like, and
you suck at planning. Uh,
if people are confused about what to do,
and I'm like, okay. And then he's like,
look, okay, you're good with people. So,
and you like people to be happy.
So you avoid conflict.
You are creative. You like
new ideas, so you don't view,
don't pay attention to the routine stuff.
You're comfortable in chaos.
So you don't plan like these strengths
are all like their own weaknesses and
disguise. Like, um, so,
and there's no one who's like 10 out of
10 on everything. And that's, that's why,
um, so, you know,
there's a lot different philosophies
on what do you do as a feedback and you
know,
the play more your shanks 30th,
I think you need at least to get your
weaknesses to a point where they're not
like destroying the company.
Um,
but generally you want to play to your
strengths and that's one of the key
effective executive tenants.
Um, but other than that,
uh,
and I think just sell foreign,
like trying to understand yourself on
all kinds of different dimensions is
really valuable. And I talked
about the Enneagram, uh,
in your book. Uh, and
that's, it's sort of like,
I would call it like
a useful Myers Briggs.
So most people are familiar with Myers
Briggs. It's a personality typing system,
but then you read it and it's like reading
a personality quiz on the Internet.
You've sort of, you remember he had some
letters and there's like some stuff,
but you don't actually
do anything with it. Uh,
I found enneagram to be
similar in terms of it's, uh,
there are a limited number
of personality types,
but it's much more of a theory about what
fundamentally motivates people, what,
what demotivates them. Um, and so, uh,
I know we don't have a ton of time,
so I'd just say like, check it out.
Enneagram is very valuable. Like I do
it. My Tea, I was, I was super skeptical.
I was like, this sounds like a
cult. Um, and it kind of is. But,
um, it's been very helpful
both to do individually and
with your team because it,
it just, you sort of, what you
learn is like, okay, here are the,
here are my blind spots. I was
like, I'm an enneagram seventh.
These are like totally textbook strengths
and weaknesses of a seven that they
like. They like new things.
They like, uh, they're,
they're comfortable and came on in chaos,
but then they can become distracted
and, and you know, and unreliable, um,
conflict of way and things like that.
So it just knowing you
always one way or another,
you always want to have an accurate map
of like, what do you need to work on? Um,
how were you, how were you
introduced to Enneagram? Well,
so it's through my cofounder.
Uh,
but then Mirage was introduced to
it through a guy named Gentry who,
who was the founder of mailbox, who
worked with us for a, for a while, says,
you know, call it three or four
years ago. And then Ross was like,
you're going to love this. It's
great that it. Ah, and I'm like,
it sounds super weird. Um, but he was
right. So it's, it's been super helpful.
Awesome.
Well,
I know we don't have a ton of time left
and maybe sometime we'll do a follow up
with some wine and I'd love to talk to
you more about your cadence and so on
with an executive coach. Maybe we can
get to it another time, but I thought,
I thought we could wrap up with another
thing that you mentioned in the book,
you know, tribe of mentors, but
I'd love to hear you talk about it,
which is the tennis ball
circle and the number 30,000.
Can you tell us where this
comes from and what that means?
Sure. So, uh,
I did the commencement
speech for Mit back in 2013.
Um,
and I was like,
the whole premise was I'm like, all
right, what do I got? I'm like, I'm 30.
I don't really like, I'm a Chi. Wait
20 years. I'll say something like,
way more insightful then. But I'm like,
all right, well, I kind of, the prompt,
the prompt I came up with was like,
well, what do I wish I had known?
What would I tell my 23 year old self?
Um,
and if I could sort of send a cheat sheet
back in time, what would it have on it?
And what I would put on that little cheat
sheet is a, as you said, a tennis ball,
a circle and the number 30,000. So, um,
the tennis ball is really about finding
that thing you can become obsessed with.
And so when I think about like Dropbox
or even just other side projects,
like the Poker Bot,
like I am both most productive and
happiest and most successful. And like,
it's like when all those things line up
or when the thing you're obsessed with
overlaps with something, the world
really needs, um, uh, or values. So,
um, but, but like don't saddle, like find
something that, uh, the tennis ball was,
sorry. The, what is it, where
does the tennis ball come from?
I had this like really
lazy fat dog growing up.
Um, who would, uh,
but when you showed her food
or you showed her tennis ball,
she would be just to, to
just like go nuts. Um,
and so you throw a tennis ball for it.
So it was like, she just as like this,
it was like watching like,
like ham running on twigs or something.
You're like, it's like
super, it's just bizarre.
It's just funny. Like, and so
I was like, I, I'm, I'm like,
what you want is to have like
that ridiculous expression
on your face and just
got to kind of be so obsessed with
something that you just don't care about
anything else. Not overdo it,
but like, but the point is like,
find something that I'm not
just passionate about, but
like that, just like that,
that,
that you can become obsessed with and,
and just really love and something you
would do even if you weren't, you know,
even if I want your job. Um, then
the circle concept is really,
there's a saying by a guy
named Jim Rone that you're,
you're an average of the five people
you spend the most time with. Um,
and I found that to be super true. So,
and then, so the, and the upshot is like,
chooses to choose wisely.
So whether that's the literal five people
you spend the most time with or just
in the environment you end. So being, um,
like going to a or just find
an environment that will
pull the best out of you.
Um, and so, and I think
that's been true for me.
Going to MIT really taught me like
what a good engineer looks like.
Um,
and it's both inspiring in
terms of watching all these
people who are super like
capable, but then also you get jealous
and you're like, oh, I, you know,
I want to be that good and see you want
to harness that kind of negative energy
and to pushing yourself to work harder.
So, and that's what that was true.
Whether it's school or being in
y Combinator with other founders,
like friendly competition there or with
my friends who were starting companies,
being in San Francisco, all of
those contributed massively to, um,
to us, uh, to us making it. Um,
and then finally, 30,000, uh,
is, is, is really about, do you
have everybody lives on average,
humans live on average for 30,000
days. I was at first, I was like,
okay, yes, this is like a clinical
truth. Not terribly interesting. Um,
because I think I had just moved to San
Francisco and as an a and I was just
like, I couldn't sleep. So I was just
like on the Internet reading stuff.
And I came to, became across that and
I remember being like, Huh, okay. Um,
and I opened the calculator and I'm
like, all right, I'm 24 at the time,
24 times three, 65. I'm like, Oh my
God, I'm like already 8,000 days now.
Um,
so this idea of like life unfolding
infinitely in front of you is actually not
really true.
Um,
and so it's really important to not just
make everyday count but also understand
that like,
think of life more as an adventure or a
story more than how you think about life
as when you're graduating college,
which is like their life up until you
graduate college is just like a series of
checking off boxes and like getting
ready for stuff and performing. Um,
and all of your worldly
achievements can be,
are averaged into a GPA. And so every
mistake is like brings that number down.
And like it's something you
have to like obsess over.
And then college graduations the first
day where that's not really true anymore.
You don't really have a GPA anymore
and you're not an average of all your
successes and failures. Like you
should change your mindset to life.
And also just think of it more just
making a story that's interesting,
not just not trying to be perfect because
I think that's a trap that a lot of
people fall into. So anyway, those are
when I thought about, um, you know,
if you were to play everything
over again a hundred times,
who knows what would happen. But if
I could just hand back a cheat sheet,
that's what I would put on it.
That's who you'd put a tennis ball
circle and the number of 30,000.
Well,
drew,
I know you have a very, very busy, uh,
time ahead of you and I'm
sure today's no exception,
so it'll let you get back to your day.
But do you have any closing comments?
Asks,
uh,
suggestions or anything else for
people who are listening to this?
Any, any kind of parting
comments before we wrap up? Uh,
let's see. So I, um,
I think I just don't, don't, don't forget
to have like don't forget to have fun.
And like I said, I think at the, at
the end of it you want to have like,
okay,
there's an obsession
with avoiding failure.
And if you think of it more as the
failures aren't really that important,
it's more how you respond
and even like what you,
what you want to do is
write an interesting story.
Not like a perfect story.
Okay.
Yes, yes. And I mean, the
first thing they do with it,
well,
I shouldn't say the sort of definitively,
but it's like a lot of screenwriters
who are experienced, we'll,
we'll say you have to create characters
and the protagonist who on some level
the audience really cares about and then
torture them and then they come
out the other side will like it.
That is one of the recipes for writing.
It's successful screenplay. And, uh,
you know,
if you're part of the human condition,
it seems like that is going to be a
component I w one way or the other.
Uh, well drew, thank you
so much for the time.
I always enjoy chatting
and hopefully we get to uh,
hang again in person sometime soon,
but I appreciate you carving
out as much time as he did to,
to share your stories with everybody.
That's for sure.
Well thanks Tim is a lot of fun and for
everybody listening we will have links
to all of the books mentioned
everything else that uh, that,
that drew may send our way as
well in terms of resources,
all the things that we discussed,
hacker news, etc. In the show notes,
which you can find as always at Tim dot.
Blog forward slash podcast with all the
other episodes. And until next time,
thank you for listening.
Hey guys, this is Tim again.
Just a few more things before
you take off. Number one,
this is five bullet Friday.
Do you want to get a short email from me?
Would you enjoy getting a short
email from me every Friday?
That provides a little more soul of
fun before the weekend and five bullet
Friday is a very short email where I share
the coolest things I've found or that
I've been pondering over the week.
That could include favorite new
albums that I've discovered.
It could include Gizmos and gadgets
and all sorts of weird shit that I've
somehow dug up in the other,
the world of the esoteric as I do.
It could include favorite articles that
I've read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance,
and it's very short.
It's just a little tiny bite of goodness
before you head off for the weekend,
so if you want to receive that,
check it out.
Just go to four hour work week.com that's
four hour work week.com all spelled
out and just drop
in your email and you will get the
very next one and if you sign up,
I hope you enjoy it.
This episode is brought to you by
wordpress.com I love wordpress.
I have used it for so many years.
It's my go to platform for
blogging and free websites.
I use wordpress.com for
everything every day.
My site tim.blog is built on it.
The website's forum books,
click tools of titans,
tribe of mentors,
all in wordpress.com and the founder
Math Molan wig and my close friends has
appeared on the show many times.
The search that moment make
Tequila Ferris for quite exciting.
Whether you're looking to create a
personal blog, a business site of both,
you can make a really big impact
right out of the box when you build on
wordpress.com and if be in good company,
it's used by the New Yorker, Jay z,
Beyonce,
five 38 tech crunch,
Ted CNN time just to name
a handful and one of my
friends@googleshallremainnamelesshastoldmethatwordpress.com
offers
the
best
out
of the box SEO imaginable and quit and
it's one of the many reasons that nearly
30% of the Internet runs on wordpress.
You do not need experience or to hire
someone that's perhaps the best part.
wordpress.com guide you
through the hire experience.
They have hundreds of
designs and templates that
you can use and it's easy to
get started. There's no
need to worry about security
upgrade posting any of that.
They have a 24 seven
support and they're very,
very responsive if you've
questioned to go right back to you,
and this allows you to create the
highest quality with the least amount of
headache and friction.
So if you're building a website period,
and my friends come to me and ask
what I use, what I recommend they use,
the answer is wordpress.com
to check it out.
Do you want to get started today?
Learn more with a 15%
discount off any plant.
Go to wordpress.com forward slash Tim
create your website and find the plan
that's right for you to learn more,
take a look,
wordpress.com four slash 10 or
15% off a brand new website.
Check it out. This episode is
brought to you by 99 designs.
Whether you need a logo, custom website,
APP, book cover, or anything else.
99 designs was created to make great
design accessible to everyone. That's you,
and to make the process
as easy as possible.
I've used 99 designs for years now.
I've used the book covers some
mockups for the flower body,
which went on to become a number
one New York Times best seller.
Illustrations of all different types
for the multivolume, the Tao of Seneca,
which you can check out and other graphic
design projects for a long time now
and I've been very impressed with
the quality of their designers and
illustrators and you don't
have to take my word for it.
You should check out some of my
projects@ninetyninedesigns.com
forward slash.
Tim, I really encourage you to take
a look because you will be impressed.
99 designs.com forward slash Tim.
Then end designs has freelance experts
in more than 90 design categories in
their platform.
Lets you work directly with one designer
that you choose if you like their stuff,
which is what I did for the Tao of Seneca.
Or you can get concepts from multiple
designers and then pick your favorite.
So whether you're starting a business
or just looking for extra design, help,
resources,
etc. 99 designs has a solution right now,
you guys,
my listeners can receive a free
$99 upgrade on your first design.
To check out your first free upgrade,
please visit 99 designs.com forward slash
Tim and click the link on the landing
page. You can also find their
samples of projects from you guys,
listeners who've used 99
designs for logos, apps,
even product packaging. So check
it out. 99 designs, [inaudible]
dot com forward slash tip.